los residentes de jarquín vuelven a
evaluar los daños en sus hogares puede
que hayan escapado con sus posesiones
más valiosas sus vidas pero tienen poco
a lo que volver
chicas
vivía aquí con mi familia mi esposa y
mis dos hijos uno de ellos discapacitado
de siete años esta era mi puerta de
atrás
tras casi seis meses de guerra contra
ucrania el crimen aún no ha logrado
capturar jarquín aunque no se ha rendido
los bombardeos ya casi constantes desde
el inicio de la invasión se han
intensificado en los últimos días como
consecuencia las historias de muerte
destrucción y la consiguiente
desesperación son ahora trágicamente
omnipresentes en kharkiv hogar de una
población mayoritariamente rusoparlante
y más cercana a rusia que cualquier otra
gran ciudad ucraniana
y doy las gracias a putin por una vida
así a una edad avanzada tengo 73 años y
han bombardeado mi apartamento señor
para que este castigo para que nos hacen
esto
moscú niega haber atacado a civiles
afirmando en cambio haber bombardeado
una base temporal de mercenarios
extranjeros en la segunda ciudad de
ucrania pero la situación sobre el
terreno cuenta una historia distinta más
de una docena de civiles fueron
asesinados en kharkiv entre el miércoles
y el jueves en lo que los funcionarios
locales describieron como una de las
noches más trágicas para esta región los
misiles rusos alcanzaron decenas de
viviendas así como una residencia para
sordos y ancianos